Everyone knows that Hollywood’s built on
powerful personalities, and you can’t be
a movie star without a bit of an ego, but
you’d be surprised to learn how many famous
screen teams downright hated eachother.
Remember to subscribe and join the notification
squad for more of our videos, and share the
video with a friend whose mind would be blown
by 10 Actor Feuds You would Never Imagine
Happening.
Jim Carrey vs Tommy Lee Jones
Both the Riddler and Two-Face were out of
control as the villains of Batman Forever,
so you would think they’d get along off
set, too.
But Jim Carrey tells the story of running
into Tommy Lee Jones at a restaurant while
filming, and seeing the elder actor’s face
drain of color.
Carrey was confused, but Jones explained,
saying he hated his co-star, since he could
not “sanction his buffoonery.”
At least he said it to his face..?
Channing Tatum vs Alex Pettyfer
Audiences knew that Channing Tatum was the
star of Magic Mike, but his on-screen protégé
Alex Pettyfer had a different idea.
Tatum was against casting the actor due to
his bad boy reputation, since he’d put his
own money into the film – and turned out
to be right.
Pettyfer has since admitted that he could’ve
been more respectful, but when he screwed
one of Tatum’s friends out of four months’
rent before the film’s reshoots, this feud
was set in stone – no surprise, Pettyfer
wasn’t invited back for the sequel.
Bill Murray vs Chevy Chase
Believe it or not, these two comedy legends
only appeared together in a single film – Caddyshack.
Which is why director Harold Ramis panicked
when he realized the two never had a scene
together – but it was for a good reason.
Chevy Chase and Bill Murray had a feud going
all the way back to their Saturday Night Live
days, but both bit the bullet while filming
their scene – written completely on the
spot, which is why it’s completely separate
from the rest of the movie.
Brad Pitt vs Harrison Ford
The Devil’s Own may not be remembered as
a Hollywood classic, but the production was
messy on a truly uncommon level.
Before it was even decided if the movie was
going to focus on Harrison Ford or Brad Pitt,
it entered production, meaning the director,
the stars, and the studio were at odds.
Creative disputes over who would be the bad
guy in the end led to delays, rewrites, and
budget troubles.
Pitt made his concerns well known at the time,
and Harrison Ford later admitted that even
in the best case, he and his younger co-star
would have little in common.
C3PO vs. R2D2
They may be the dynamic duo of the Star Wars
universe, but Anthony Daniels and Kenny Baker,
the actors inside the actual droids downright
hated eachother.
The two rarely spoke to one another on set
for obvious reasons, but the feud hit a new
level when Daniels claimed he was the real
star of the twosome, and that R2-D2 could’ve
been a bucket, and no one would’ve cared.
Baker was rightly offended, but would later
say that once he realized Daniels treated
everyone that way, it was an easier pill to
swallow.
Gillian Anderson vs David Duchovny
The duo of Fox Mulder and Dane Scully made
the X-Files a household name, with their chemistry
and opposing personalities the main reason
for the success.
So fans would never have guessed that the
two actually couldn’t stand eachother by
the end of their run.
Both Gillian Anderson and David Duchovny admit
that spending so much time with one person
can drive any relationship apart, and Anderson’s
struggle for equal pay behind the scenes couldn’t
have helped.
Thankfully, their rivalry eventually turned
to friendship, with the two as close as siblings
today.
Nathan Fillion vs Stana Katic
The ABC series relied on the undeniable charm
of Nathan Fillion to succeed, with his leading
lady Stana Katic unable to resist.
Over Castle’s run, the two heroes would
grow close, and even marry – but behind
the scenes, things weren’t so sunny.
Rumors of a rift between the two leads started
early, but eventually proved true.
It’s impossible to say that the two actually
disliked working together, but the final season
split their characters apart – and another
season was planned without Katic, before the
show was completely canceled.
The truth really is stranger than fiction.
Shia LaBeouf vs Tom Hardy
Controversy tends to follow Shia LaBeouf wherever
he goes, so rumors that he had gotten into
a fight with his co-star Tom Hardy on the
set of Lawless were easy to believe.
To stay in character as a bootlegger, LaBeouf
got a little familiar with moonshine, which
may have convinced him that picking a fight
with Hardy was a good idea – and later bragging
that he put Hardy in his place.
It was Hardy who got the last laugh, though,
claiming LaBeouf was terrifyingly scary, and
a “bad, bad boy” – to a room full of
laughing reporters.
Wesley Snipes vs Everybody
Before Wesley Snipes ran into trouble with
the IRS, he was causing it as the star of
the Blade trilogy.
Stories from the set describe Snipes as a
diva, angry and suspicious that Ryan Reynolds
was being given better lines, or that his
director, David S. Goyer, was a racist.
Reynolds and his co-stars wound up filming
most of their roles without Snipes present,
which turned out to be better for the film’s
comedy.
As for Goyer?
He pretended to hire a local biker gang as
security, which put his star’s antics – and
calls to the studio to have him replaced – to
an end.
The Rock vs Vin Diesel
Fans may have thought that Fast & Furious
stars Vin Diesel and Dwayne Johnson only started
as enemies in front of the camera, but it
seems truer than most realized.
When his last week of filming the eighth installment
kicked off, The Rock took to social media
to thank his female co-stars – and call
out the men who’d shown themselves to be
“unprofessional candy asses.”
It didn’t take long for people to realize
it was star Vin Diesel he was referring to,
promising that the anger and boiling blood
in their scenes wasn’t entirely an act.
Those are the best-known feuds and on-set
rivalries we can name, but which ones have
we missed?
Let us know in the comments, and remember
to subscribe to our channel, and join the
notification squad to be the first to catch
our newest videos!